you boys ready to get your song driving
right now
yeah hit people are not to hit people
hit people don't drive through yellow
yeah honestly I really don't have any on
this yeah it's kind of drifting you just
tree shift and kind of go to left or
right it's it a little indeterminate are
you taking no I'm running into my own
self because they are stealing all the
zones bad thing guys can't help you
really it's it's a shame Jesus how do I
tell who's winning oh yeah you can't
stop by the way if you stop you lose
yeah that's yeah that is yep dude fifty
two three you guys [ __ ] that big I
know it did
oh god oh god oh god oh god no not like
this myself wait I need more people in
me oh [ __ ] is this good or bad
oh this is good just going nine trillion
miles an hour oh no no God keep oh no I
lose yes I lose also oh my god
some part of somebody's train of buses
is going so fast yeah you guys what were
you at weighed like 160 all right are we
ready you're ready to be destroyed
ladies and gentlemen oh I'm I love this
this is what you love robbed
wait wait did my guy pick anything up oh
yeah well you fool you losers you're
full diamond being full needs you meet
you're full of passengers and then you
guys drop off I mean I don't know what
it means oh god oh god whose [ __ ]
yellow I am why what's wrong how was
blue so girthy so soon hey guys so
[ __ ] huge good
2-0 take that way take that way to break
me yes I did
wait oh you can get upgrades and press
left mouse I just broke a bunch of
yellow no what no no yeah how do you
break people you gonna you gonna upgrade
if you see in your bottom left how do
you use your upgrades hey I will not
suck it I will not even who the [ __ ] is
light blue get out of here that's me
baby no [ __ ] I'm gonna shoot my goddamn
missiles at your stupid face who you
killed all of my yes I did get the [ __ ]
away from me do anything to you
everybody get the [ __ ] away from
everything I well no no no now I'm in
the water apparently you can be in the
water oh I almost stopped it Oh God just
keep going
go Bessie go [ __ ] yes I'm on bussy oh
yes there we go come on [ __ ] come on I
wanna eat that sweet oh god oh god oh
god oh
Oh God is there a way to control where
you're going in the air or do you just
rotate around
Oh piece of garbage mouth God hey hey
hey hey what what are you doing what are
you doing what are you doing what are
you do I did I did get out of here I do
I do get out of here you did this to me
get away from me I am no man you I'm no
I'm nowhere near you there we go your
train is all over the place
oh really understand what I bother in
you hi
but don't worry about me do all of you
need to be such douches do union juice
yes [ __ ] you [ __ ] what did I do to you
what did I do
wow that was really beep why did that
missile not hit you Bob I don't know I
don't know I don't know it was like
dead-on to you excuse me excuse me
excuse me excuse me thank you
excuse me bard me myself is that good no
yes it's not perfect autofellatio
oh I just realized there's a scoreboard
[ __ ] a dick
yeah there's a scoreboard no no no you
don't think hot guys blue oh dear
goodness oh I thought was better at
rocket League I would know how this
works
so many times I'm about to touch it
don't worry about where the thing is
that it's fine
Oh whoo and the goddamn it is everywhere
being piece of [ __ ] sex don't want it
don't want it keep going we all win
human I mean I would I win I had the
biggest bus when the clock ended no no
no we will never find out
I was win are we all in yeah my scar you
know this game everything ah Hawaii is
going so many boobs all around me get
out of here you dick ah gardenia you
sure could you spare a blue
[Music]
yeah that's alright I just feel
incredibly fun oh no some kind of
horrible thing is happening okay there
we go oh why is my dark teal in a
chaotic conglomeration of gang up on
pink reason the gang up on pink we
really need to get my lead was so
commanding you just hit me while I'm
down what's wrong with you I got my
first actual point yeah yes I did that's
what you get yeah why don't you go suck
one why are you here I'm gonna find you
I'm gonna suck yours where is it really
you go you try I'd like to see it I'm
going to here's here comes whatever
manna I fell off but I'm coming back oh
no no don't touch it anyway it was very
underwhelming you go away no
touchy-touchy
no leaving okay she'll have more points
than I have I will have more points let
me know get away it's mine
Oh God my train eat it pink I didn't do
anything to you you just put it right in
front of me ha ha but it's up to you to
finish oh can you put it back on this
site oh wait my horse is gone be gone
out of here we should gang up on dark
blue I'm getting up with myself right
now I can't even get over bike and what
is this insanity over here
I have cashing this in if you better I'm
not waiting anymore
it'd be - baby - Pinker oh by 20 by 20
I'm winning
no not anymore I was winning by Oh fine
thank you yeah that's that's great yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's my [ __ ] going why are you over
here I'm here wait wait dead body just
in this level oh you like it
I don't what is that do
why did you touch it touched it then I
will touch you I win I win I win I want
all winners this game wait wait several
ways we can all agree definitely way to
go in I won set this whole game yeah
that's that that's the game did you all
you guys get in I'm up in here yeah I'm
in there why did that happen
stop looks like I have all the points Oh
someone over there already someone's
over blue
back tit seconds suckle upon anybody I
think you should just bequeath would
thank you one delicious
who did that
thanks so much for sure oh I just went
the opposite direction of where it's
Bond which is great that was me and
cruel and alone
yeah who did that i you might a hundred
and fifty pink or the nine pink that's
like 150 thank you oh okay well that's
not good 150 big girthy pink dollars 209
[Music]
okay it ended Purple's are so big I
can't go anywhere yes you know it's you
know it's to be true the car sitting
happens now bro get out of here light
blue hit the pig hit the pig get the pig
I'm in the river I'm in the river hi can
i doing you oh no no no not my train I
just like to point out that I'm
destroying who's green and who decides
to just create a roadblock here for
nobody to go through Green's really
[ __ ] ruin and everything in existence
you want to go route why do you monster
there we go ah just you
I can't you keep someone kill blue
avenge me No
absolutely not don't kill anyone kill
purple kill lose your purple no I'm dead
so it doesn't your purple says win on my
screen maybe you shouldn't bend such a
piece of garbage with your stupid greed
and piece-of-shit bus everywhere go into
the city you're so obsessed with my poor
bus that's a great point this game in
first person okay first person mode oh
Jesus yeah well you just gotta look for
it I see it I see it no no I see it mine
I hit a building yeah you want to hit
the building then hey Frank not to he's
this double victory I get it I've got
ease I can't see anything anywhere Wow
oh my god Jesus Christ creation of green
Oh God yeah I'm we're gonna get that who
died I did
Oh why'd you die I crashed into a
building and couldn't get out well don't
do that
don't touch this wood this one's for me
I was gonna touch it
now touch it it's for me it was going to
don't respect any now yeah how's it feel
yes the spectator boat is awful yeah
flying in first person
feels like there's a little more control
to it oh where am i what am i it was god
dang it you guys keep fighting it before
I do
yeah well when you're good at the game
you know when you're really good at the
game Jesus it was because I'm awesome so
many posters just floating around don't
even know which color I am oh dear Oh
I'm inside of it is this existence sure
you just need to relax man yeah you just
gotta jump powers can't see who's
winning oh that felt like me that God
all my sound is stopped world is quiet
now I have infinite boost oh no I don't
i had infinite boost so god I'm right
here did I touch it did I touch it I
can't tell I can't navigate oh God
there's too many bosses my god hell you
say god I'm coming hang on wait for my
noxious after that one I really like
that in first person that's fantastic
god I want a mode where it's just
infinite boost and all you do is fly and
just [ __ ] it I'm a nice toothpaste color
I am teal
No are we doing first person yeah oh oh
god are we oh it's the only way to play
baby
Oh way to fly oh I don't want to fly by
now yeah get out here so many explosions
Oh God okay so the bp1 gives you an
infinite job does it oh that does oh I
didn't know that I got damnit
Oh actually my chance oh that was gonna
be mine yeah well you know it's fine
I'm not bitter I'm a team is good no no
I have to destroy that which I love yeah
but actually I'm for yourself haha how
did you even do that it's fine it's fine
I don't have [ __ ] I don't know [ __ ] Oh
first person again yeah yes oh you
cheater garbage man yeah garbage always
stink man take that that's fine yeah
good hit good hit Bob good hit oh come
on it's mine I apologize yeah sorry
about that
that is unfortunate I'm a single oh
that's so unfortunate wait oh you hate
to see it you hate to see it mark could
you [ __ ] get out of my way no not to
second oh no my girth knows no limits
oh I was we counter heated I shall fly
now and none shall touch - everything's
good everything's good I fly thing there
huh yeah yeah it looks like someone shot
me while I was in there so you know not
good not good
Bob is [ __ ] destroying you guys dude
first person is what's up I'm on the
piggy again really harsh new changes cut
the mouse market yes where's Josh I'm
never launching this game again
[Music]